as a creature that had spent so much of
its existence and captivity surrounded
by beings it deemed disgusting
scp-682 was not used to having seemingly
unlimited freedom to explore and was
even less used to having tolerable
company and yet hear the hard to destroy
reptile was entering into level 21 of
the back rooms with not one but two
accidental companions the back rooms
were bad enough when faced alone and the
addition of annoying Hangers On only
made the whole experience that much more
unbearable for 682 even the fact that
scp-682 was free of the foundation was
little consolation when being contained
in the back rooms was proving to be a
far more terrible fate than a lifetime
spent in a vat of acid the first and
most important was that the infinitely
lovable and perfectly blue Hyacinth
Macaw Jerry who scp-682 had known for
only 12 levels of the back rooms but
would undoubtedly kill everything in
sight if anything happened to him of
course the lizard tended to want to do
that anyway but the sentiment was strong
nonetheless 682 felt the complete
opposite way about the plush Dino
backroom's entity 198 that had been
tagging along ever since level 18. there
was something about its dumb little
smiling face that filled 682 with a
boiling rage not to mention the fact
that having the animated toy around
would mean that Jerry's much desired
attention would be split between it and
682 three was most certainly a crown and
if the tiny legged Scamp wasn't so
proficient at dodging 682's unprovoked
claw strikes and tail slaps the hard to
destroy reptile would have cut the plush
Dino out of the equation but 682 would
need to conserve some energy for the
entities that lurked in the back rooms
level 21 a series of four hallways Yes
you heard that right there were only
four hall
in level 21 not infinite hallways not a
Labyrinth of hallways not even the same
four hallways repeated in an endless
loop four hallways that's it as a
consequence of the much smaller scale of
level 21 the roving bands of entities
that normally are spread out across a
much larger Dimension find themselves
clustered together in the cramped linear
span of the four hallways even a medium
entity account can be impossibly
dangerous when an Explorer is faced with
the iconic backrooms monsters at once
well unless those entities are up
against
scp-682 go on make my day it roared the
approaching Regiment of death moths
death rats facelings hounds bursters
smilers clumps and even some completely
unknown weirdos marched like soldiers
specifically the gorgonites from the
1998 action comedy movie Small Soldiers
because these things were equally messed
up looking and equally known for
fighting losing battles however scp-682
charged Into The Horde it noticed that
this time the entities were a bit more
tactical in the way they approached
combat was this also a unique property
of level 21 or was the back rooms taking
a page out of 682's book and adapting to
new threats the clumps vaulted with
their many hands and rolled along the
walls to get behind 682 while the hounds
and facelings made a frontal assault the
smilers soon joined the clumps on the
other side using their uncanny ability
to shift through the Shadows the death
rats nod at 682 from underneath
attacking the reptile's footing and
doing everything they could to distract
it all the while the death moths and
bursters acted as artillery shooting
acidic slime from a safe distance behind
the other entities or in the case of the
death moths from above just Out Of 682's
Reach
scp-682 almost had to applaud the
entities for getting their act together
it was facing a mobile task force made
up of rejected Dungeons and Dragons
monsters a valiant effort but doomed to
end in their defeat these entities were
not the foundation and scp-682 refused
to lose to a bunch of aberrations
cosplaying as a containment Squad it was
time to give them a taste of their own
medicine and during the attacks of many
entities at once
scp-682 became a chimera of monstrous
features stolen from various backrooms
entities the freakish grin of a Smiler
spread across its face while the
grasping arms of a clump emerge from its
back along with an impressive pair of
defmoth wings the ever disgusting acid
shooting pustules of a burster appeared
across 682's body pointing in every
direction like the Cannons on a naval
ship now fully optimized to take down
the organized entities with their own
weapons
scp-682 roared out of Battle Cry death
to the back rooms all burster ponds
ruptured at once forcing the entities to
take evasive action most did not get far
thanks to 682's countless Clump arms
which grappled and held on to everything
within reach as 682 pulled the entities
in towards its teeth and Claws the
shredding began their numbers were thin
quickly and the once organized Legion
fell in disarray with entities
indecisive lean making desperate attacks
or tactical Retreats now the resemblance
between this Skirmish with the entities
on level 21 and the ones that scp-682
had with mobile task forces back at the
foundation containment facility was
nearly perfect except this time no Force
military or otherwise would come along
to put 682 back into confinement now
this was freedom
cherry that was classic 682 I still got
it the reptile boasted
Jerry replied in the excitement of
Victory
scp-682 almost forgot that entity 198
was still here watching the aftermath of
the Carnage with the same smile it
always wore nevertheless 682 felt rather
strongly that the plush Dino was judging
it nobody asked you plush Dino he
grumbled on some level the plush Dino
was most likely aware of
scp-682's overwhelming animosity but it
was also a simple entity driven by
appropriately simplistic desires it had
its own reasons for staying by the
reptile side in its usual role on level
18 the plush Diner would seek out
explorers lost in their own traumatic
memories and guide them towards safety
whatever safety meant in the back rooms
the adorable entity had an inherent
biological or Supernatural radar sense
that allowed it to detect individuals
experiencing distress and suffering
since the majority of backrooms
explorers are human the margin of
distress that the plush Dino could
detect and respond to was kept within
the relative limits of normalcy for this
reason the plush Dino had never
encountered any being that carried more
feelings of distress than 682 the hard
to destroy reptile was from entity 198's
perspective the most mentally pained
creature in existence the plush Dino's
top priority was now to be a Beacon of
Hope For What it saw as a victim of the
ultimate forms of unaddressed trauma of
course it was a non-verbal entity and
possessed no telepathic or empathetic
abilities so conveying it's more
wholesome therapeutic intentions to
scp-682 was next to Impossible
especially since a being as aggressive
and hateful as 682 would be wholly
unreceptive to the notion of hugging
away its problems but this would not
stop entity 198 from making the
rehabilitation of its now ketter class
charge the meaning of its oddly specific
existence even if that meant leaving
potentially thousands of tortured human
explorers eternally Lost In level 18.
the plush Dino was now embodying the I
can fix him mentality to its logical
extreme after trying several doors
throughout level 21 it was clear that
the majority of them simply LED back
into other parts of level 21's four
hallways much like the doors in a chase
scene from a Hanna-Barbera cartoon
eventually 682 and his party members
stumbled Upon A dimensional tear in the
side of one of the hallways this looked
like the entrance to the next level so
682 decided to throw caution to the wind
and step through into level 22 the car
park which unlike some of the previous
levels was in fact infinite for whatever
that was worth a few damaged 50's era
automobiles occupied the parking spots
their metal rusted and torn to shreds
more curiously there was what appeared
to be a circus tent wedged between some
of the concrete supports there were no
entities around the main area of level
21. so scp-682 entered the tent thinking
that it was perhaps another exit for
once it seemed that the back rooms
weren't subverting the reptile's
expectations as inside the tent was none
other than the inside of a tent rows of
plastic folded chairs sat within facing
a wooden Podium on an elevated stage
this tent was made to hold many humans
but strangely there was only one an old
man in ragged hiking gear that stood
amongst the chairs scribbling notes into
a journal of sorts he wore an enormous
backpack that swelled with supplies and
unusual bottled items though the Fallen
Nation avenstable lived inside of tents
like this one the old man muttered to
himself he then looked over his shoulder
and noticed scp-682 glaring at him he
closed his journal and stared back with
an increase positive look on his face oh
a new entity I don't get to see that
every day the human laughed though why
is it with entity 7 and entity 198 if
those numbers are so important
mine is six eight two
scp-682 growled entity 682 as the old
man scratching his white beard how have
I never heard of you I am not an entity
scp-682 snapped back I'm an anomaly the
old man Shrugged and said I fail to see
the distinction that makes two of us 682
thought anyway anomaly 682 I'd advise
against attacking me I'm rather busy
collecting notes for the kalag Institute
and I can be a force of nature when I'm
interrupted I've dealt with bigger and
scarier things than you so I'll wander
off and leave me to my work the old man
had far too much confidence for 682's
liking who did this human think he was
anyway it was not going to be talked
down to like that especially not by
someone from any kind of Institute it
was go time without another word the
reptile began plowing through the chairs
towards the elderly human who in a
display of agility unexpected for
someone his age gracefully hopped across
the chairs to the stage successfully
evading 682's charge well I did warn you
the old man reached into his pack and
produced a small dark object carved of
lapis lazuli stone it resembled a Scarab
or dung beetle and there were
hieroglyphics across the base of it the
old man chanted a prayer to the stone
invoking the name of the Egyptian god
kepri and causing the scarab's wings to
extend a great blue light was emitted
from the lapis stone and a terrible
droning Buzz hit 682 all at once
stunning it for a moment the old man
left to the wing Beetle hovering in the
air and proceeded to draw two more
unusual objects from his knapsack in one
hand he held a bottle of fine red powder
while on the other held a bottle that
appeared to contain electrical energy he
hurled both at scp-682 and ducked for
cover over behind the stage upon impact
the bottles created a large explosion of
electrical Flames which immediately
caused the entire tent to go up the old
man drew a large knife and cut his way
out to the tent leaving 682 behind to
burn as the structure collapsed the
human made a break for the nearest
concrete ramp leading down to the lower
areas of the parking garage he looked
back to see a heavily scorched 682 in
Hot Pursuit but no signs of entity 7
Jerry and entity 198 the plush Dino The
Entity no the anomaly was more durable
than the old man expected and far more
willing to endure pain if it meant
chasing down prey in a desperate bid to
keep the monster from Catching him the
old man retrieved a crystal and metal
artifact from his inventory it was known
as a pocket and true to its name it
contained a pocket Dimension which could
store large objects and release them at
the command of its user earlier in his
trip through level 22 the old man had
stored a couple of damaged cars in the
pocket in case he needed to cover from
an attacking entity as 682 gained on him
he summoned the cars back from the
pocket causing them to land in the
reptile's path while ineffective at
stopping the creature it gave the old
man enough time to take a sharp turn
around a corner and find a hiding spot
amongst the other tents and broken down
cars the seasoned Explorer had one last
trick of his sleeve and he prayed that
it would bring an end to this terrifying
encounter as scp-682 sniffed the air
searching for him the old man produced
another bottle of unbridled energy this
time derived from the same kind of
dimensional riff found on level 21. he
hurled it towards the reptile not a
moment too soon and watched in awe as
the bottle exploded the floor and
ceilings began to crumble as arcs of
energy surrounded 682. what is this
scp-682 thought feeling itself being
pulled from this reality and into
another seconds later the reptile was
gone in a flash of energy the old man
wiped his brow in relief that was close
wherever 682 was after being warped by
the dimensional Terror this particular
Explorer had managed to escape its wrath
for now but would others be so lucky
want to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now go check out could
scp-682 be contained in the back rooms
and scp-682 Slaughters through the back
rooms for more back rooms Carnage